all right we predicted yesterday and it
was so obviou this is as i say many
times this is not like a pat on the back
that this was some amazing prediction uh
it was obvious that now that the pfizer
coveted vaccine is fda approved
you were going to start hearing from the
right saying i don't know that we can
trust this approval
this may have been rushed the biden
administration may have accelerated it
when it really shouldn't have been
approved yet or whatever the case may be
now why is this relevant this is
relevant again because i only you know i
know that the right is now just about
owning the libs
i don't care about crap like that okay
what i want is
let's get people vaccinated so the icus
can start emptying out and so that we
have room in hospitals for people who
get into a car accident get hurt at work
whatever the case may be that my
priority is health okay
one third of those who were resisting
the vaccine said
if and when there is a full approval
uh then i will go and get vaccinated so
that's a really important thing so we
care about
how
um media and the right react to news of
the approval
here is a fox news segment that opens
yesterday by saying
was it rushed
was it rushed take a listen
a fox news alert for you now the fda
just giving full approval to pfizer's
copic vaccine it's the first vaccine to
get that full approval and in record
time too that has critics asking if the
process was rushed was it well let's
bring in admiral brett gerard former now
okay
there are people who said
it's unfair to show only that because dr
brett jarrar comes in and says no it's
safe i agree with you
but it's still teasing it you're leading
with that and it's fox news and you know
the audience now dr brett gerard comes
in and he says it's safe but notice that
40 seconds later
the other anchor bill hemmer is going to
say by the way what took so long wait a
second was it rushed or did it take too
long which is it why can't you guys
decide health and human services
assistant secretary and of course he was
our testings are so tell us a little bit
sir about what this moment means to get
full approval sir
well this is a very big moment in uh
operation warp speed history in the
history of our vaccines our fight
against the pandemic prior to this we
had emergency use authorization what
that really meant is that the public
health benefits outweighed the known and
potential harms what this says today is
we know the benefits we know the harms
and this vaccine is safe and effective
and every confidence can be given to
that americans should feel very good
even better than they did yesterday
about getting the vaccine yeah what took
so long
oh man
you know the critics are worried this
was done too quickly it was it could was
it done too quickly no absolutely not oh
what took so long to get this approved
come on guys come on guys so
let's listen to a little bit more
well it is a complicated process and i
know there are many many good
professionals incredible professionals
at the fda i was acting commissioner um
it does take a while because all the
data is looked at in detail you know
every page is turned the facilities are
inspected
however uh again as i've said before i
think it's unconscionable that the biden
administration does not have an fda
commissioner even nominated to provide
leadership it might have been a little
faster but it is complicated
there's a lot of material and americans
should feel very confident in the
process some have said that they were
hesitant to get the vaccine and point
into this lack of full approval and how
do you think the administration and its
goal to try to get more people
vaccinated can utilize this news
well i think the american people will
utilize the news the poll said about 30
percent of those who have not been
vaccinated right would become vaccinated
feel very confident about that once the
vaccine received full approval that just
happened the vaccine is fully approved
and i'm very hopeful that this will
push people uh over the edge to go get
the vaccine because it is okay so you
guys get the point so so listen um
the full video shows the guests saying
uh it wasn't rushed and people should
get the vaccine that's a very good thing
that's good the framing up front
and the fact that fox still seeds the
talking point was it rushed can we trust
it their first instinct is to lead the
segment with can we really even trust
this approval
which is already what many fox news
viewers are prone to believe can we
really trust this and so i get that just
the first 12 seconds were floating
around yesterday and there were people
saying it's dishonest to say
that the entire segment meant to tell
people that it was rushed you're right
you're right and there were some people
who only played the first 12 seconds
i've played the full two minutes okay
you're right bret gerard says it's safe
and it wasn't rushed i played the rest
and i'm glad that that's what the guest
said but this is a channel whose
audience lives in 15 second sound bites
many of whom want to believe it was
rushed and many of whom will see that
question asked and the rest of the stuff
doesn't matter
and so this is really important bret
gerard cited the same study i've been
citing one third of the vaccine
resistant have said
resistant maybe is not a good word
because it means something else of the
vaccine hesitant have said
if there's full approval i will go and
get vaccinated let's now see if they do
we'll have more coverage of the reaction
from right-wing media to the full
approval later on in the show and also
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman's show
one of our sponsors is geology the place
to go for men's skin care geology helps
men find a simple skin care routine that
works it's personalized for you by a
dermatologist and geology can help with
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design a personalized
skin regimen for your needs you'll get a
30-day trial with the products they
recommend to try them out if you like
how it goes they'll keep sending it to
you these aren't bogus miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need i
took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologist matched me with a
regimen that's just great for me i've
been happy with the results my skin's
looking great i can actually see a
difference go and take geology's free
quiz and when you use my link right
underneath this video
you will save up to 40 percent off your
first paid month